thank you very much for coming to Cody's
we're very excited to have this all-star
lineup to talk about and read from
Jessica Mitford the American Way of
death read incident we've got a bang-up
lineup tonight so and we have c-span
here filming so we want to get right on
it our first person to speak it's
Jessica Mitford husband mr. Bob true
haft and he's going to come up and be
our master of ceremonies and then we'll
also be hearing from karen leonard leah
guard chick Doug foster Christopher
Hitchins and with a surprise musical
conclusion so please welcome mr. Bob
true hapten we'll get going
thank you very much
welcome friends with this all-star group
of speakers I'm going to keep my remarks
to a minimum I as a matter of fact I
won't make any I'm gonna read something
to you I'm very grateful to Bob Gottlieb
who saw this thing through
well deca was alive he was a constant
advisor and after her death he was my
concept advisor also when when I started
work on the book after Dickens yeah I
looked through the all the material she
added there and I found a couple of
dozen letters from Decca to Bob Gottlieb
I didn't find one from him to her and
those she was asking technical questions
so I called him and I said Bob look
you'll be my editor for this book won't
you just as you will for Decca he said
of course my will be I said well I found
all these doctors letters from Decca to
you not one from you to deco what
happened where are they he said well I
so enjoyed Becca's letters in the so
amused by them now I just call her up
and we have a long chats on the
telephone so I said well my letters
won't be that amusing I thought you'll
have to write - really he promised he
would he wrote once but what he wrote
was very good and I was so glad that he
took from me the burden of writing this
little note to explain the history of
the book at happy lunch with me in 1995
Jessica Mitford Decca to everyone who
knew her agreed to prepare an updated
version of her classic work the American
Way of death
Peschel reports in her introduction to
this volume we had worked on that book
together in the early 60s and had
remained close friends both through a
number of other publishing ventures and
after our professional relationship came
to an end a lot had changed in the
funeral trade since the first edition
was published in 1963 and not many of
the changes with a better the plan was
to retain from the original everything
that still applied and to add new
chapters as needed such as the report on
the chip your own conference will not
selling an investigation of the new
international funeral Giants a global
village of a dead and on the count of
the failures of the Federal Trade
Commission in the wake of the new
legislation that was written largely in
reaction to the first edition of the
book certain materials for example
example most of the chapter on floral
tributes the Menace of pio pio please
omit was excised as no longer relevant
although I suspect that the floral
deluge that followed Princess Diana's
death would have evoked a new commentary
on this subject and of course a great
deal of updating particularly prices of
prices was needed most of this work
including the new chapters mentioned
above as well as the introduction and
the final chapter new hope for the dead
Decca finished before her unexpected and
mercifully swift death from cancer in
1996 won't remain to be done and was
accomplished by three people first there
was a brilliant research investigative
assistant research and investigative
assistant Karen Leonard who took on
increasing responsibilities and indeed
soon found herself drawn into the
funeral reform movement the second
crucial person was Lisa Carlson probably
the most influential figure in that
movement who made many generous
contributions to the book not least of
all whereas it was her extensive help
with the panel the multiplet chapter I'd
never write that pay now die poor which
says so the complex realities and booby
traps
inherent in pay and advance funerals
finally duck as husband Robert rue have
had made her a promise just before she
died the distinguished labor cell
couldn't write that and civil rights
lawyer who had worked with her on many
of her books would retire from his
practice and see this book through to
completion this he heroically did almost
of her final week Dekker was reveling in
the job bombarding me and other pals
with faxes that gleefully skewered the
more famous Moffatt us and or
hypocritical hijinks of the industry she
could be ruthless savage even when she
was on the warpath but she never stopped
laughing which is perhaps why the
American Way of death was not only
welcomed as a necessary corrective in
1963 but was so enjoyed as a piece of
writing and why it still reads so well
today the American Way of death
revisited is being published exactly 35
years after the original edition
unfortunately this correction corrective
is necessary as it is a necessary today
as it was then fortunately it is being
applied Robert Gottlieb
I'm that brilliant researcher Karen
Leonard but the truth is the most
brilliant thing I ever did was to go to
work for Jessica Medford and I just come
back from a tour in New York and
Washington doing a lot of reviews for
the book and it was so much fun because
occasionally I would come across
somebody who really knew her as Queen of
the muckrakers and they would always ask
me the same question which was what was
she really like you got to hang out with
her what would that like and it was so
exciting and it was always a surprise so
I want to read a little bit to you from
her first chapter which is about the
event I attended with her when she went
to the funeral directors meeting and she
was invited to go to the special event
in Tiburon
it's called appropriately not selling
when funeral directors have taxed me
which they have and not infrequently
with being beastly about them in my book
I can confirm in good conscience that
there's hardly an unkind word about them
in fact the book is almost entirely
given over to expounding their point of
view it is chock-a-block with their wise
sayings observations exhortation and
philosophical reflections called from
penal trade magazines and interviews
with individual funeral directors and
official spokesmen I did mention that
like every other successful salesman the
funeral Salesman must first and foremost
believe in himself and his product and
that they long to be worthy of high
regard to be liked and understood a most
human longing Mershon merchants of a
rather grubby order preying on the grief
remorse and guilt of survivors or
trained professional men with high
standards of ethical conduct the funeral
men really would rather prefer to fit
the latter category to what extent if
any has their outlook changed over the
decades I had a rare opportunity to
serve a representative cross-section of
the industry in action when to my
astonished delight I was invited by
enhanced editor of mortuary management
to be a featured speaker at a two-day
funeral service seminar to take place in
October 1995 in Tiburon California
that's like Ralph Nader being invited to
address General Motors friend said for
me the anticipation was akin to that
felt like a five-year-old promised a
trip to Disneyland or a teenager offered
a big part in Hollywood movie the
reality did not disappoint
Tiburon is in Marin County rich aside
from being one of the richest
communities in the country as a
cremation rate of about three times that
of the national average and thereby
hangs a tale for a while the seminar
topics could have fit handily into any
trade meeting agenda maintaining an
effective work force responding to
community trends that are public
relations etc the subtext of many of
speech was how to extract maximum profit
from formation we gathered in the
Tiburon lodge meeting Hall overlooking a
huge swimming pool a congenial wash
pitch kind of crowd consisting of 44
Funeral Directors from around the
country five presidents of casket
companies a few insurance men the
president of Dean our airbrush systems
and various spouses welcoming the group
our host Ron hast glumly mentioned that
there had been plenty of protest about
my presence at the seminar not the least
of which was a state funeral directors
associations executives dire threat to
have his members cancel their
subscriptions to mortuary management the
audience was soon put at ease by the
first speaker perhaps appropriately from
the world of big business John Baker
spry young former manager of the United
Airline subsidy with a staff of one
thousand responsible for all employee
programs is subject how to maintain an
effective workforce which he attacked
con brio with much folksy banter and
down-home humor his first question to
the audience established the tone who's
minding the store while you're away
someone answered my wife are you sure
you can trust her gales of laughter and
be sure to chitchat with your customers
but our customers don't talk the casket
salesman said I'm gonna stop right there
because this is where I want to tell you
what really happened underneath that as
we were sitting there scribbling notes
listening to this man talk about giving
dinosaurs to your employees their
balloons to them etc and he's going all
these these samples that he could do and
he says to the audience let them use
your condos over the weekend and
suddenly Decca's bolts up right and she
looks at me scribbles furiously
later that evening we trade notes back
and forth and I had to be the bearer of
bad news to tell her no he didn't say
let them use your condoms over the
weekend she's oh my my hearing is going
later that evening we go out to dinner
and we're followed
founded by funeral directors now we're
in the restaurant you're all politely
sitting at tables waiting for us you
know for her to get finish and so she
finishes dinner and she rises from the
table suddenly a man who I'm trying to
give you the type he as I always called
him
no next these are these guys that just
don't seem to have a neck and from the
south and he was this big jolly guy and
he comes up he uses up the DECA and
clasp her hand and his both his fat
chubby little hands and he looks at her
and says I just want you to know that I
paid $4,000 and traveled all these miles
just to be with you today and she says
goodness you shouldn't have done that
you should have given me the $4,000
I'd have flown out to see you and that
was what traveling with Decker was like
you never knew what was going to come
out of her mouth and it was always a
surprise and always a circus so I want
to thank you for being here tonight and
want to welcome the next speaker and
giving you more insights into Dec in
this wonderful book the American way of
death revisited
I am Lea gar chick and it was a friend
of Decca's and I feel really lucky
because I was kind of hoggish and
grabbed the part I really thought was
most delicious to read what deca would
have called the killing part who
actually it supposed to killing because
it's about embalming but more than more
than anything I think I remember her
voice in the way she'd stress things
like that the killing part and do tell
so I listened to Decca all the time
anyway this is a model for Annan bombed
a to being bombed being okay the
preparation room in any of the better
funeral establishments has the child in
sterile look of a surgery and indeed the
embalmer restorative artist who does his
tours there is beginning to adopt the
word derma surgeon appropriately
corrupted by some mortician writers is
Demi surgeon to describe his calling his
equipment consisting of scalpels
scissors augers forceps clamps needles
pumps tubes bowls and basins is crudely
imitative of the surgeons as is his
technique acquired in a 9 or 10 month
most high school course and embalming
school you supplied by an advanced
chemical industry or with a bewildering
array of fluid sprays paste oil powders
creams the fixer soft and tissue shrink
or distended at Snead as needed
dry adhere restore the moisture there
there are cosmetics waxes and paints to
fill and cover features even plaster of
Paris to replace entire limbs there are
ingenious aids to prop and stabilize the
cadaver a very pose headrest the Edwards
arm and hand positioner the repose block
to support the shoulders during the
embalming and the through foot
positioner which resembles an
old-fashioned Stotts mr. John H Eccles
president of the Ecole school of
mortuary thus describes the first part
of the embalming procedure in the hands
of the skilled practitioner this work
may be done in a comparative a short
time and without mutilating the body
other than by slight incision so slight
that it scarcely would cause serious
inconvenience if made upon a living
it's necessary to remove the blood and
doing this not only helps in the
disinfecting but removes the principal
cause of disfigurement student
discoloration so we wring it out okay
the blood is drained out through the
veins and replaced by embalming fluid
pumped in through the arteries as noted
in the principles and practices of
embalming every operator has a favorite
injection and drainage point the fact
which becomes a handicap only if he
fails and refuses to forsake his
favorites when conditions demanded
typical favorites oh I wish I knew
medical terms are like new where these
arteries are are the karate'd artery
femoral artery I know that someone here
jugular vein and subclavian vein you
just guess there are various choices of
embalming fluid if flex stone is used it
will produce a mild flexible rigidity
the skin retains a velvety softness the
tissues are rubbery and pliable ideal
for women and children it may be blended
with the mg products companies lifelike
tint which is guaranteed to reproduce
nature's own skin texture the velvety
appearance of living tissue sun tone
comes in three separate tints suntan
special cosmetic tint moderately pink
about three to six gallons of a diet and
perfume solution of formaldehyde
litterin borax phenol alcohol and water
is soon circulating through mr. Jones
whose mouth has been sewn together with
a needle directed upward between the
upper lip and gum and brought out
through the left nostril with the
corners raised slightly for a more
pleasant expression if he should be buck
tooth his teeth are clean with banana
and coated with colourless nail polish
his eyes meanwhile a cluttered with our
clothes with flesh tinted eye caps and I
cement the next step is to have it mr.
Jones with a thing called a trocar this
is a long hollow needle attached to a
tube it's jabbed in the abdomen and
poked around the entrails and chest
cavity the contents of which are pumped
out and replaced with cavity fluid this
done and the hole in the abdomen having
been sewn up
mr. Jones face is heavily cream to
protect the skin from burns caused by
leakage of other chemicals and he's
covered with a sheet and left unmolested
for a while but not from
there's more in store for him he's been
embalmed but not yet restored and the
best time to start the restorative work
is 8 to 10 hours after embalming when
the tissues have become firm and dry the
object of all this attention to the
corpse it must be remembered is to make
it presentable for viewing in an
attitude of healthy repose the embalmer
having allowed an appropriate interval
through the lapse returns to the attack
and now brings into play the skill and
equipment of sculptor and cosmetician is
it hand missing casting one in plaster
of Paris is a simple matter for
replacement purposes only a cast that
the back of the hand is necessary this
is within the ability of the average
operator and is quite adequate it's not
going to play the piano in the casket so
you just have to do what shows if a lip
or two when those or in year should be
missing the embalmer has it has hand a
variety of restorative waxes with which
to model replacements porous and skin
texture uh students are simulated by
stippling with a little brush and over
this cosmetics are laid on head off the
capitation cases are rather routinely
handled ragged edges are trimmed and
head joined to torso with a series of
splints wires and sutures it's a good
idea to have a little something at the
neck a scarf or high collar when time
for viewing comes swollen mouth cut out
tissue is needed from inside the lips if
too much is removed the surface contour
can easily be restored by padding with
cotton swollen neck and cheeks are
reduced by removing tissue through
vertical incisions made down each side
of the neck the opposite condition is
more likely to present itself that of
emaciation his hypodermic syringe now
loaded with massage cream the embalmer
seeks out and fills the hollowed and
sunken areas by injection in this
procedure the backs of the hands and
fingers and the under chin area should
not be neglected positioning the lips is
a problem that recurrently challenges
the ingenuity of the embalmer closed too
tightly they tend to give a stern and
disapproving expression ideally in
bombers filled the lips should give the
impression of being ever so slightly
parted the upper lip protruding slightly
for a more youthful appearance this
takes some engineering however as lips
tend to drift apart lip drift scans
sometimes being remedied by pushing one
or two straight pins through the inner
margin of the lower lip and then
inserting them between the two upper
front teeth if mr. Jones happens to have
no teeth the pins can just as easily be
anchored in his Armstrong face former
and dental replacer another method to
maintain lip closure is to dislocate the
lower jaw which is then held in its new
position by wire run through holes
drilled through the upper and lower jaws
at the midline there's a sentence here
that uses a French phrase I'm not gonna
even try it if mr. Jones has died of
jaundice the embalming fluid will very
likely turn green does this deter the
embalmer not if he has intestinal
fortitude masking paste and cosmetics
are heavily laid on burial garments and
casket interiors are Kirk color
correlated with particular care and
Jones is displayed between rose-colored
lights
friends will say how well he looks death
by carbon monoxide on the other hand can
be a rather good thing from the
embalmers for your point one advantage
is this fact that this type of
discoloration is an exaggerated form of
natural pink coloration this is nice
because the healthy glow is already
present in needs but little attention
the patching and filling completed mr.
Jones is now shaved wash and dress a
cream-based cosmetic available in pink
flesh suntan brunette and blonde is
applied to his hands and face his hands
are his hair is shampooed and comb his
hands manicured for the horny-handed son
of toil special care must be taken cream
should be applied to remove ingrained
grime and the nails clean if he were not
in the habit of having them manicured in
life trimming and shaping is advised for
better appearance never questioned by
Kim thank you
I'm Doug Foster
and I want to read a little bit from the
end of the book or the part of the book
that represents some of the additional
work that deca did with Karen and lisas
help and then with Bob's help after
after she died been putting this great
book together this that there was a
really lousy review in The Chronicle a
book review that said there isn't much
new material here and that's that's just
not true the guy couldn't have looked
very carefully at the at the afterwards
I'm not an important point I want to set
this up just by saying that deca was a
an amazing of force of nature and one of
the things that friends of hers liked to
do was to matchmake because it was
always interesting to see what she would
do with somebody else who might be
somewhere near a match for her and when
I heard that Karen and and decas
research had led to service Corporation
International which is the conglomerate
that does many many funerals around the
world that she would be going to Texas I
said you have to go and see Molly Ivins
the two of you together against the
funeral directors that was a a match
made in heaven from my point of view and
i I've heard Molly tell the story of
their visit Molly's idea was in addition
to doing going to the corporate
headquarters they they had to go
together to the mortuary museum in
Houston but that was a trip that was
that would absolutely had to be on on
the docket so they went together there's
a huge museum dedicated to the mortuary
Arts in Houston it takes up an entire
block and it has the various exhibits
history the anthropology you know the
economics the sociology of weary arts
are all there so if you can picture deca
and Molly together that's enough for
starters but walking in to the
Museum of mortuary arts and stopping at
the first exhibit a big large sign that
says embalming and Decca thought that
might be a good place to start so they
sat down and there was a film you could
push a button to listen to on and and
the announcer said the act of embalming
was first invented by the Egyptians at
which point Decca leaned over to Molly
and said now there was a society where
the funeral directors really completely
got out of hand this comes from the
chapter called a global village of the
dead and focuses on the way in which s
CI Service Corporation international a
great name for a company has
rationalized funerals of the modern
funeral JP Morgan in February 1996
carries an optimistic headline Service
Corporation international a strong 1995
and position for 1996 here also the
continued softness in the death rate is
perceived as a bit of a problem
throughout 1995 the death rate in North
America was lower than the historical
trend case volume was down 3% year the
year but there was a silver lining the
JPMorgan bulletin continues with
extremely cold weather in North America
during the first two months of 1996 the
first quarter death rate should be
closer to the historical trend of
approximately eight point at eight
deaths per thousand it is our
understanding that where extreme weather
conditions have been experienced in
Europe and North America volume did in
fact increase during the first five
weeks of 1996 and Europe that care is
well on its way to meeting or exceeding
its plan for the first quote
the twin strategies that go for it to
account for SC is phenomenal success
both concepts entirely new to the
funeral industry are clustering and
anonymity of the 22,000 Funeral Homes in
the United States the vast majority are
small operations doing somewhere between
50 and 100 funerals a year critics of
the industry attribute high prices to
this factor they point out that the
owner who performs one or two funerals a
week must nevertheless maintain a full
complement of in bombers equipment
purses funeral cards and sales personnel
to serve these few customers it's
full-time pay for part-time work as one
analysts put it s see I entered this
picture with the force of a hurricane
swept away the antiquated methods of the
old timers and substituted clustering
the latest in streamlined mass
production borrowing from the successful
techniques of of McDonald's where food
preparation and management functions are
centralized SC I first buys up the
carefully chosen selection of Funeral
Homes cemeteries flower shops and
crematoria in a given metropolitan area
the next step is to move the essential
elements of the trade to a central Depot
clustered in this hive of activity are
the hearses limousines utility cars
drivers dispatchers and bombers and a
spectrum of office workers from
accountants to data processors or kept
constantly busy servicing at vast
savings the needs of the half dozen or
more erstwhile independent funeral homes
needless to say the savings obtained via
the cluster approach are not passed on
to the consumer s CI prices have risen
sharply with the targeted increase of
30% and markets like Houston where SC I
with its 20 funeral and cemetery
businesses has a predominant position 75
percent of the market its prices
according to a recent survey average 60%
higher than those of the independence in
the area in Washington DC 40% higher one
of the advantages of this kind of
clustering and rationalization of the
industry is that you can write one
script for every encounter
that these various workers are going to
have in in a funeral home and and deca
and Karen got a hold of the s CI
directive about how families are to be
treated when they walk into any one of
these homes all of which have the name
of the local proprietor but in fact a
run by s CI so here's the here's the
script which Decca likened to a TV
mini-series script as your arrangement
comes to the casket selection stage we
would like you to use the following
approach this is written in the script
mr. and mrs. blank I would now like to
assist you in selecting a suitable
coffin gasket or casket for length
interselection room and proceed to stand
behind the classic royal in the middle
of the room guide the family to stand in
front of the classic I would like to
introduce you to our classic royal this
design is that of a European
contemporary coffin it is elegant
finished in rose mahogany mahogany gloss
with fine line gold engraving on the
sides this unit combines expert
craftsmanship with a fully satin lined
interior it is priced at a thousand five
hundred and ninety five dollars now move
to your right and stand behind the
classic royal here to the right we have
our most recent design and we call this
the classic royal it combines the shape
of both a coffin and a casket to give us
the very popular wider shape with a rose
mahogany mahogany gloss finish this item
combines the versatility of Australian
native timber and craft work it is
priced at one thousand nine hundred and
ninety five dollars move to the white
pearl on the stand to your left this is
our white Earl it has been designed in
the traditional coffin shape the
material from which it is made is craft
wood it is priced at 909
five dollars now proceed to the hand
over in your right back corner and stand
beside it there follows a glowing
description of the hannover which is
priced at two thousand nine hundred
ninety five dollars dough or counter
part then tells the family I will be
just over here move to the near to the
top of the stairs if you have any
questions the final stage direction
allow your family as much time as they
need that ensure that you do not leave
them in the room read their body
language the casket prices quoted for
Australia may be increased by a factor
of three or more for the u.s. equivalent
no to the use of the word coffin a
definite no-no in the lexicon of the
American human trim but down under the
word casket may mean is elsewhere in the
english-speaking world except for the
United States an ornate box for jewels
or other valuables Australians are just
now being indoctrinated by FCI
into its undertaker bestowed meaning of
burial receptacles SC is improved upon
the somewhat primitive list of okay
words and its recent manual for the use
of its cemetery salespeople a special
terminology has been developed in
keeping with the Memorial Park plan just
as well-designed tablets flower gardens
and statuary of genuine merit have taken
the place of bleak and often garish
tombstones so words that are pleasing
and their suggestion of beauty and
dignity are used in place of those that
are harsh and linked with depressing
ideas certain words and phrases long
associated with cemeteries sometimes
increase sales resistance because they
suggest images of a negative morbid and
depressing nature the following is a
list of positive action words and
phrases in contrast to those that are
negative the latter should as far as
possible be eliminated from all sales
vocabulary there with a partial list of
SC is deathless words casket code not
hearse
display area not casket interment space
not grave opening interment space not
digging grave closing interment space
not filling up gritted the gravedigger
he has a problem he may not fill the
grave with dirt you must fill it with
earth his task will be preceded not by a
funeral but by a memorial service the
decedent was not sick he was ill and he
didn't die he passed on his remains were
not embalmed that they were prepared
there were no mourners present for the
service only relatives and friends
and of course if that language of
gruesome euphemism wasn't being used to
turn a profit it would be called
political correctness and be denounced
everywhere around them um I don't know
how many of you comrades brothers and
sisters remember the Republican
convention in Miami that nominated
Richard Nixon to be President I'm sure
some of you do that they the scene was
of the delegates leaping up and down in
unison holding a big sign which said now
more than ever I used to watch a mystic
I know this is reminding me of something
and now more than ever not without she
was or not rattle it's finally pointed
out to me it's it's the opening of one
of the most beautiful stanzas of Keats's
ode to a nightingale which as you may
remember it says now more than ever
seems it rich to die and the idea of
these energized Republican bunnies doing
this all unaware reminded me of one of
my favorite sayings which is that in the
midst of life we are in death
I never tire of saying that and I think
that the finest as a result stave of the
book that we met - oh not like to say
commemorate to celebrate which I read
when it first came out and I reread and
reviewed for the Los Angeles Times
earlier this year more more never
convinced that the greatest passage in
it is its title the genius of a thing
lies in in its name remember that in the
1950s and 1960s one of the one of the
subliminal perhaps the subliminal main
subliminal Keystone and key worth of
state authority and state propaganda and
of the Cold War was the very phrase our
way of life it was in defense of the way
of life that people were supposed to buy
a game with high-pressure euphemistic
salesmanship fallout shelters and equip
them with chemical toilets and enough
drinking water for three days and a
kitty litter box and all the other
requisites for maintaining this way of
life in the event of them feminine
Holocaust it was in defense of the way
of life that small children were bullied
and blackmailed into doing
duck-and-cover exercises in school and
made to prepare for extinction at any
moment under the supervision of the
teachers who were supposed to be
enlightening them in the level
and broadening their tiny minds remember
if I never it's not it really should
never be possible to forget that we live
in a state or under a state that in a
manner not known since the late medieval
period claims as all right the right of
life and death over all its citizens and
not over them alone over everyone else
living on the fact times the right to
exterminate them or mass and to make
preparations for this and run and
maintain them and test them hourly and
use them at any time as a whim if need
be in defense of a way of life that is
that that is the permanent dictatorship
that we live under everyone here in this
room is in fact sitting here listening
to me in a uniform in a front line and
their lives can be taken at any time
that's what the defense of the way of
life meant then means now it was never
better summarized that preparation in
preparation for that event and the the
arming of the thermonuclear also and the
creation of an undemocratic and
unelected nuclear state to back it up
with every means of surveillance and
intimidation never better
describing in one very beautiful phrase
of the late dr. Martin Luther King who
said that it was some it was magnificent
in its horror because it was the it was
the preparation to commit suicide and
genocide at the same time and not only
of course for all of us and everyone
else living on the planet but everyone
who's ever been born or died and being
buried since recorded time began because
once there was no one to remember that
anyone had ever been here everyone would
have been killed all over again and
Shakespeare would have been killed in
goethe and schiller milton and the loss
of richard nixon would I think have been
a small consolation dr. King was very
busy on other fronts at the time he made
that speech one of the extraordinary
things about the positions he took about
war and no tourism was that he would had
we would have had every excuse to say
I'm
I'm heavily engaged on other fronts I
did indeed have that excuse I was often
told to stick to his business as a
colored man and not involve himself in
these more complex questions but if you
recall there was a bit of a struggle in
the states of the former Confederacy and
indeed in the buildings of federal
government in Congress as to whether or
not people with the wrong amount of
military and the skin were entitled to
claim the right of American citizenship
and the southern and former Confederate
rhetoric against this saying this should
not happen a must nor the bar in the
schoolhouse door against it was in
defense of the way of life and of course
this has made for true huffed did her
bit lunging around in those states at a
time it was extremely dangerous to do so
driving around with petitions to try and
save Willie McGee from being executed
because the way of life did mean that
people had to be killed in its defense
and could be and the person who killed
them could not be punished or brought a
book
so by ridiculing and by deconstructing
this key phrase she did I think an
enormous amount to unblock the mental
and moral a log jam of the time as well
as to draw attention to the obvious fact
that that exploitation by Capitol
continues beyond the grave it used to be
said of people at the Salvation Army
that they offered pie-in-the-sky
supposed to be a criticism but at least
they were offering firing this gun it
was said of others well you know perhaps
you can't take it with you no you can't
take it with you suddenly said that the
free enterprise system we want and you
can't have it up there either we want
all the surplus value you've ever
accumulated in this vale of tears before
you go and we want it now and by
confronting that it seems to me again a
tremendous cultural and political point
was being was being made and as a result
the book will be read as long as the
ethos of capitalism remains sovereign
which means that it's got ahead of it
along the sale and I would otherwise
like to a predictive one one can't have
everything now I was very much honored
by Bob true Huff when he asked me to
speak
the memorial for Decker which took place
in London and after the memorial was
over I met someone hadn't seen for a
long time we've been sitting quietly in
the front row and we have a drink Lady
Mary Stearns who was born Mary Churchill
with the eldest daughter of Winston
Churchill and it's called sales cause
she's the widow of a fantastic we are
attractive bloated conservative
politician and I was touched that she'd
come because there was obviously a
kinship between the Churchill family and
me and she told me the following story
which I'll see if I can relate point
Philippe pungently trust me bear with
you the thing you have to know for it to
make sense is that some it's one of the
things oddly enough they don't teach you
in school at the beginning of the Second
World War the British establishment had
to send quite a lot of its members
overseas where they could do no harm
because it was thought if they were
allowed to remain in the country they
would form a Quisling or Vichy
government in the event of the Nazi
invasion they had to get rid of their
with the 8th by making him governor of
the Bahamas for that reason the Bombers
are Prince of Wales and his gorgeous
wife and they had to do that to Lord
Halifax the Neville Chamberlain's
foreign secretary of Munich the furthest
thing of people sending him was to make
him ambassador to Washington that's what
he was
you have to need to know this for the
story to work so Mary
Soames told me this he said we were all
frightfully worried about death though
all of us girls for one thing we'd all
been madly in love with Esmond so their
only jacket had them had the nerve to
really go for him and elope with him we
were all frightfully worried we were
terribly upset when ESMA was killed we
knew that Dekker was all by himself in
Washington so when Daddy
that's Sir Winston Churchill we're
setting off for his summit with
Roosevelt we all formed up on him and
said you can't come back from this
summit unless you do something for Decca
so picture it it's 1940 the Nazi Empire
Germany German parents were spread
itself oil of almost the whole of the
face of Europe Church and desperation is
going off to see the famed
manager who holds the keys to the
equally famed no less Fame arsenal of
democracy and he can't come back unless
he does something about Becca and he's
very worried about it and he calls her
in he's in the White House
staying with myself she comes in recent
with a baby
clamped on the hip and says sir no he's
fine with me
well rightfully sorry about husband and
everything and he also brought her the
news that there was literate he'd been
posted missing but he wasn't coming back
they weren't gonna find it he'd been
shot down over the North Sea and said
look but I there's a silver lining I've
talked to our ambassador yeah and he
says that for a well-spoken and well
turned out gal like you
there'd be a wonderful job we could give
it you could start tomorrow well-paid
house goes with it lots of money you
just have to charm Americans we know
that be British and do all the things to
do so well he thought you know not bad
he taken time off from crucial Memphians
life to fix all this up she's got up off
the bed where she was sitting said if
you imagine if you imagine for one
second that I would going work for that
filthy Nazi appeasing bastard Lord
Halifax you have many many more things
coming and swept out okay no job recent
widow baby on the hip take your job and
shove it
Churchill flew back this entire case of
which do you mean the Roosevelt bit or
the decadence but the Decker bit they
when he said it went very badly it went
very badly indeed I tell this story
partly because I know that it will it
will make it will make it seem for many
people as if Decker's in the room when
they get the story and then for another
reason which is that the ancients used
to say that courage is not in itself one
of the virtues it isn't listed as one of
the cardinal virtues on its own however
it does squeeze in as the quality or
faculty that makes all the other virtues
possible and I would be making if I was
a saint if opposed to go on about
Decker's virtues but here's the quality
she had all the time was courage and the
courage to do what she did that day was
just one example of it and since it's
one of the less well known I thought I'd
I thought I'd introduce it but a great
chest approach is it always has been
traditionally fortitude in the face
precisely in the face of death that's
when you find out whether you've got it
or not not just say you're not afraid of
it but you overcome
that fear it seems to me that mrs.
Mitford true haft acquitted herself very
well by that definition not only was she
against the exploitation of death by the
what I call in my review the the
furniture Kratz of the the ghastly
mausoleum and um mortuary industry not
only did she make their life and
continues to make it shameful and
something of the hissing and the by word
where the decent people at you know
Dylan she was also against all the false
consolations that sir people offer for
death against the mean is self-evident
nonsense of religion the belief in
afterlife all the incarnation or any
other any kind of superstition always
ridiculing it with a very more than
written against that against the cult of
death at sentimental hesitant and an
attempt to look away to avert the gaze
by various forms of of denial and then
of course finally when her own turn Pema
she knew it would be faced it with
exactly the combination of stoicism and
humor and and resolve and attention to
comradeship that one would have
predicted so that by my character is
about four victories over the great
Reaper and it enables us to say in her
memory and in her honor tonight and with
pride death be not proud